Camilla Harris was a pressed this week
and about her position on abortion
specifically when the cutoff should be
right when does a baby go from being a
meaningless clump of cells to being a
person with rights
that was the question and here is her
answer or her non-answer as the case may
be
what is it that you believe I mean what
week of pregnancy should abortion access
be cut off
we need to restore
protections of Roe versus Wade we're not
trying to do something new well that was
fabulous because it was about viability
which could be anywhere between 20 to 24
weeks and but so no no no no no no
let me be very the Women's Health
protection act let me be very clear
from day one the president has been
clear I have been clear we need to put
back the protections
that are in Roe v Wade into law since
the Supreme Court took it Congress has
the power and ability to pass
legislation to put those protections
back in law and Joe Biden will sign that
bill
so that is what we want but does it need
to be specific in terms of defining
and where that guarantee goes up to and
where it does not at which week of
pregnancy we need to put back in place
the protections of Roe versus Wade we
are why I'm asking you for this question
because we're not trying to but we're
not trying to do anything
that did not exist before June of last
year
we are saying it wasn't crafted into law
and that's why I'm asking for the
specifics there because Republicans say
the lack of a precise date in cutting it
off you know this
they say that allows Democrats to
perform abortions up until you know
birth which is ridiculous which is not
accurate and it's ridiculous and it's a
mischaracterization of the point no the
point is
I am being precise we need to put
into law the protections of Roe versus
Wade
I am being precise I'm precisely
avoiding answering anything remotely
resembling that question she says that
that's ridiculous that's my favorite
part of that uh that exchange there it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous that anyone
wants abortion up until birth she says
and yet she also won't say
that she doesn't want abortion up until
birth so this is always the way these
people play the game
when you say oh well you you you're okay
with the abortion up until birth that's
absurd
okay so you don't want abortion up until
birth well that's besides the points
no that's the whole point
um
and if we can all agree like if you
didn't know any better and you watched
that clip you would think well I guess
we all agree that apparently that
abortion uh you know aborting children
up until birth is insane
you've got fully developed infants who
can survive outside the womb
obviously this is a person
like we can all agree on that
um and if we can all agree on that and
you would think we can based on the way
she responded that's ridiculous uh then
then where is the cutoff
if the cutoff is not birth where is it
and she can't answer that or she won't
answer it
because her cut off is in fact earth
that is the cutoff
for all of these people oh if not a
little bit after that
um
that is uh that that is the cutoff
and they won't say it
they won't say it because they realize
how how uh terrible it sounds and is
sounds terrible because it is terrible
but that is their cut off all of them
uh and it has to be
you know this is the this is always the
point when it comes to the abortion uh
debate
is that
obviously there have to be cut there's
there's a a cut off somewhere like
there's there's a point you've got an
unborn child
okay you've got an unborn child here
over here you've got
a 30 year old man
everyone agrees the 30 year old man is
uh is a person well I don't have the
left we've agreed with that we have a 30
year old woman over here everyone agrees
with the 30 year old woman is a person
and yet they raise questions about the
well widowed The Unborn uh the fetus not
really a person
okay well at what points
if this quote unquote fetus is uh not a
person and third year woman is a person
then it what and and that third year old
woman used to be a quote-unquote fetus
in her past at what point did she become
a person with rights you have to be able
to answer that you have to be able to
and then algae I've used before is if if
you can't answer that if you can't
answer it
if you're going to do the Barack Obama
Dodge his Infamous Dodge of us above my
pay grade when personally if that's what
you're saying
then you more than anyone really should
be opposed to abortion
because then what you're saying is well
abortion might be killing a person I
don't know
and then an abortion that's like it's
like it's like firing a gun into a dark
room
you might hit somebody and kill someone
you might not you don't know
but if you fire a gun into a dark room
without knowing if there's anybody in
there and you kill someone
you're going to jail
that's murder at least manslaughter
because you knew that there could be a
person there
and you fired the gun anyway
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like walking your dog in public
without securing it on a leash most of
the time you'll probably be fine but
what if one day your dog runs away or
gets dog napped it's better to be
careful especially when it's as simple
as using expressvpn every time you
connect to an unencrypted Network in
cafes hotels airports Etc your online
data is not secured any hacker on the
same network can gain access to and
steal your personal data expressvpn
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
that they can't do that and take a
hacker with a super computer over a
billion years to get past expressvpn's
encryption expressvpn works on all my
devices phones laptops tablets and even
on my Smart TV it's so easy to use just
fire up the app click one button
and get protected that way get an extra
three months of expressvpn free to
expressvpn.com Walsh that's exp
rssvpn.com Walsh to get protected today
expressvpn.com Walsh
did you know that if you have a credit
card with a ten thousand dollar balance
and you only pay the minimum every month
without putting any additional charges
on the card it'll take you eight and a
half years to pay it down that doesn't
even include the extra fees from
compounding interest you can't let that
happen instead call our friends at
American financing learn how your home
equity can help you pay that balance off
much faster potentially saving you seven
hundred dollars a month maybe more it
really is possible to get those kinds of
savings while also getting out of debt
faster and it could even happen in as
little as 10 days when you call American
financing so why put this important call
off pick up the phone right now see what
they can do for you there are no upfront
or hidden fees and if you start soon you
could delay up to two payments right off
the bat so even if your credit isn't
perfect you need to call they have a
credit card team that may be able to
help you and the service is also free so
call American financing today at
866-721-3300 that's 866 721 3300 or
visit American financing Dot net that's
americanfinancing.net
so if you're not willing to answer the
question when does personal begin or if
you're if you're saying you don't know
you can't
then then it then what you're saying is
that we might be killing a person
um
so that just doesn't work you have to be
able to answer the question
and what we find out is that when it
comes to uh personhood there's only two
cutoffs that make any sense it's it's
there's only two options that make any
logical sense really there's only one
there's only one which is conception
because that that is when the this this
you know that 30 year old woman
uh we Trace her her uh her history back
we go you know we we go back and back
and back what we're going to find is
there's a certain moment when that
person who's now a 30 year old woman
came into existence and that was
conception
so there's this unbroken chain we trace
it back back back even when she was in
the womb we find there was one moment
when she came into existence and it only
makes logical sense to say that she was
a person in that moment
if you're going this if you're not going
to say that then the only other kind of
like
uh at least tangible cut off would be
birth
but then you're claiming that it that
something magical so that's that's a
tangible like cut off that we can all
understand
but it doesn't make any sense because
now you're saying that something magical
happens as the child emerges from the
birth canal
all that's happening is the child is is
moving locations
from the womb to the to the hospital
room
um
and something magical happens in a
moment to imbue the baby with person or
that doesn't make any sense either
so that cut off doesn't work and then
we're back
at conception
and that's where this conversation
always leads
as pro-lifers we're the only ones you
might not like the answer
of one person who begins we're the only
ones who can answer it we're the only
ones who have a defensible coherent
cogent answer no one else does
for if you're not going to say
conception then you're left with
something completely arbitrary
that you've just come up with on your
own even if you say something well it's
a
yeah let's say you're at the 15 weeks
why is that it
so 14 and a half weeks not a person at
15 weeks magically you are it doesn't
make any sense
so she knows all that but you know the
real here's the real answer from these
people and this is true of pretty much
everyone who supports abortion
and this is also why this conversation
never goes anywhere it can't go anywhere
can't go anywhere because you can't have
a a fruitful dialogue when there's one
side of the of the discussion that isn't
being honest about what their position
actually is I can't engage with your
position or refute it if you won't say
what your position is and what Kamala
Harris's position actually is
is that
unborn babies are people
and we should be able to kill them
that's the position every pro-abortion
person that is actually their position
that yeah obviously they're human beings
they're people and we should be able to
kill them we should be able to kill
babies
that's their actual position uh they
won't say it out loud they know they
can't say that out loud
so they're left flailing around like
Camilla Harris was there thanks for
checking out this video if you'd like to
listen to my full podcast on the go you
can check out the Matt wall show on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts